next time I talk to you we'll get into
the poker plane because you're like an
unbelievable poker player you're like
the best celebrity poker player there is
and uh probably one of the best poker
players out there
You've Won what's the most money you've
won 55 000.
100 000 100 125
000 when I did the NBC heads-up
championship
000.
she's the real deal I mean you are a
poker I was so bummed though because I
should have gone to the finals but I was
so upset how much would you have won if
you went to the finals
I don't remember the next level is
probably 250 and 500 for first and
second if I got 125 it must have been
something like that but I I played I was
playing against Paul wasicka who went on
to win it right and Paul was like look
it really didn't matter what hand you
picked I was he was just getting good
hands he said every hand I got all of a
sudden was just so good it didn't matter
I'm like uh I was so bummed but I was
really practicing
um the secret then this was when the
secret was big yeah and I started really
vigorously practicing that and
envisioning and manifesting like
the outcome and the wins that works you
really think it worked
if you commit yourself to it and you
believe it
it can work I mean it's manifestation